the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello and welcome to 601 I'm Danny
Freeman on the lecturer one thing you
should know about today is that there's
a single handout you should have picked
it up on your way in that's available at
either the two doors what I want to do
today in this first lecture is mostly
focus on content but before I do that
since 601 is a little bit of an unusual
course I want to give you a little bit
of an overview and tell you a little bit
about the administration of the course
601 is mostly about modes of reasoning
what we would like you to get out of
this course is ways to think about
engineering we want to talk about how do
you design how do you build how do you
construct how do you debug complicated
systems that's what engineers do and
we're very good at it and that we want
to make you very good at it we're very
good at it then you know that from your
common everyday experience laptops are
incredible as we go through the course
you're going to see that laptops
incorporate things from the tiniest
tiniest level things so small that you
can't see them they're microscopic the
individual transistors are not things
that you can see we develop special
tools for you even to be able to
visualize them and yet we conglomerate
billions of them into a system that
works relatively reliable now I realize
I'm going out on a limb because you and
you say things like that then things
always fail but I'll go out on a limb
and say for the most part the systems
that we construct are very reliable we'd
like you to know how you think about
making such a complicated system and
making it reliable we want to tell you
about how you would model things how do
you gain insight how do you get
predictability how do you figure out how
something will work before you've built
if you're limited to try out how things
work by actually constructing it you
spend a lot of time constructing things
that never make it we want to avoid that
by where we can making a model analyzing
the model making a prediction from the
model and using that prediction to build
a better system on the first try we want
to tell you about how to augment the
physical behavior of a system by putting
computation in it that's a very powerful
technique that is increasingly common in
anything from a microwave to a
refrigerator we'd like you to know the
principles by which you do that and we'd
like you to be able to build systems
that are robust to failure that's a
newer idea it's something that people
are very good at if we try to do
something and we make a mistake we know
how to fix it and often the fix works
we're less good at doing that in
constructing artificial systems in
engineering systems and we'd like to
talk about principles by which we can do
that so the goal of 601 is then really
to convey a distinct perspective about
how we engineer systems now having said
that this is not a philosophy course we
are not going to make lists of things to
do if you want it to be robust we're
going to learn to do things by actually
making systems this is an introductory
engineering course and so you're going
to build things the idea is going to be
that in constructing those things we've
rigged the exercises so that some of
those important themes become
transparent so we the idea is this is
introductory engineering you'll all make
things you all get things to work and in
the process of doing that learn
something about the bigger view of how
quality engineering happens so the so
despite the fact that we're
really about modes of reasoning that
will be grounded in content we selected
the content very broadly from across the
EECS EECS is an enormous endeavor we
can't possibly introduce everything
about EECS in one subject that's
ridiculous however we wanted to give you
a variety we wanted to give you a sense
of the variety of tasks that you can use
that you can that you can apply the same
techniques to so we want to introduce
modes of reasoning and then show you
explicitly how you can use those modes
of reasoning in a variety of contexts so
we've chosen four and we've organized of
course around four modules first module
is software engineering then signals and
systems and circuits and probability and
planning even so even having chosen just
four out of the vast number of things we
could have chosen there's no way we can
tell you adequately we can't give you an
adequate introduction to any of those
things either what we've chosen to do
instead is focus on key concepts
represented by the asterisks the idea is
going to be we choose one or two things
and really focus on those deeply so you
get a thorough understanding not only of
how that fits within for example the
context of software engineering but also
how that concept ramifies into other
areas notice that I chose I tried to
choose the stars so they hit multiple
circles that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to not only introduce an
idea to you but also show you how it
connects to other ideas so the idea then
is to focus on a few we hope very well
chosen applications that will
demonstrate a variety of powerful
techniques our mantra the way we intend
to go about teaching this stuff is
practice theory practice there's an
enormous educational literature that
says whether you like it or not
people learn better when they're doing
things you have a lot of experience with
that you have a lot of experience on the
other side too I'll try to forget the
other side or at least try to wipe it
from your brain
momentarily to focus on your more
fundamental modes of learning when you
were a kid and you were learning your
first language you didn't learn all the
rules of grammar first you didn't learn
all of that letters of the alphabet
first you didn't learn about conjugating
verbs first you learned a little bit
about language you started to use it you
ran into problems you learned a little
more about language you learn to confirm
words like feed me to higher level
concepts like hey what's for dinner so
the idea is that you learned it in an
iterative process where you learn some
stuff tried it out learn some more stuff
tried it out and it built up there's an
enormous literature and education that
says that's exactly how we always learn
everything and so that's the way this
course is focused what we will do is for
example for today we'll learn a little
bit about software engineering then
we'll do two lab sessions where you
actually try to use the things that we
talked about then we'll come back to
lecture and we'll have some more theory
about how you would do programming and
then you go back to the lab and do some
more stuff and the hope is that by by
this tangible context you'll have a
deeper appreciation of the ideas that
we're trying to convey so let me tell
you a little bit about the four modules
that we've chosen the course is going to
be organized on four modules each module
will take about one fourth of the course
first thing we'll look at is software
engineering as I said we don't have time
to focus on or even survey the big idea
all of the big ideas in software
engineering it's far too big so we're
going to focus narrowly on one or two
things we'd like you to know about
abstraction and modularity because
that's such
important idea in the construction of
big systems so that's going to be our
focus will begin in today's lecture
we'll begin talking about modularity and
abstraction at the small scale how's it
affect the things you type as
instructions to a computer but by next
week we're going to be talking about a
whole bigger scale by next week we're
going to talk about constructing
software modules at a much higher level
in particular we'll talk about something
that we'll call a state machine a state
machine is a thing that works in steps
on every step the state machine gets a
new input then based on that input and
its memory of what's come before the
state machine decides to do something it
generates an output and then the process
repeats we will see that that kind of
and abstraction state machines has
there's a way to think about state
machines that is compositional that you
can I think of as a hierarchy just as
you can think of low level hierarchies
within a language I'll say a lot more
about that today
so the idea will be that once you've
composed a state machine you'll be able
to join two state machines and have its
behavior look just like one state
machine that's a way to get a more
complicated behavior by constructing two
simpler behaviors that's what we want we
want to learn tools that lets us compose
complex behaviors out of simple
behaviors and the tangible model of that
will be the robot we will see how to
write a program that controls a robot as
a state machine that's certainly not the
only way you could control a robot and
it's probably not the way you would
first think of it if you took one course
in programming and somebody said you go
program the robot to do something what
we will see is that it's a very powerful
way to think about it for
exactly this reason of modularity the
bigger point that we will make in
thinking about this first module is the
idea of how do you make systems modular
how do you use abstraction to simplify
the design task and in particular we
will focus on something that will call
pcap when you think about a system we
will always think about it in terms of
what are the primitives how do you
combine them how do you abstract a
bigger behavior from those smaller
behaviors and what are the patterns that
are important to capture so the bigger
point is this idea of pcap which we will
then revisit in every subsequent model a
module ok second module is on signals
and systems that's also an enormous area
so we only have time to do one thing the
thing that we will do is we will think
about discrete-time feedback how do you
make a system that's cognizant of what
it's done so that in the future can do
things with awareness of how it got
there a good example is robotic steering
so the idea is going to be okay think
about what you do when you're driving a
car and think about how you would tell a
robot to do that same thing here's a
naive driving algorithm I don't
recommend it but it's widely used in
Boston apparently I find myself to the
right of where I would like to be so
what should I do
turn left I'm still to the right of
where I'd like to be what should I do
turn left oh I'm exactly where I should
be what should I do
go straight ahead that's a bad idea and
what we'll see is that perfectly
innocent looking algorithms can have
horrendous performance what we'll do
is try to make an abstraction of that
we'll try to make a model we'll try to
capture that in math so that we don't
need to build it to see the bad behavior
we'll make a model
we'll use the model to predict that that
algorithm stinks but more importantly
we'll use the model to figure out an
algorithm that will work better in fact
we'll even be able to come up with
bounds on how well such a controller
could possibly work so the focus in this
module is going to be how do you make a
model to predict behavior how do you
analyze the model so that you can design
a better system and then how do you use
the model in the analysis to to make a
well-behaved system the third module is
on circuits again circuits is huge we
don't have time to talk about all of
circuits we'll do very simple things
we'll focus our attention on how you
would add a sensory capability to an
already complicated system the idea is
going to be to start with a robot I
guess this is brighter start with our
robots and design a head for the robot
the robot comes from the factory with
sonar sensors the sonar sensors are
these things there's eight of them they
tell you how far away something that
reflects the ultrasonic wave is as they
come from the factory the robots can't
sense light what you'll do is add like
sensors the goal is to make a system to
modify the robot so that the robot
tracks light does very simple goal and
the way we'll do that is to augment the
robot with a simple sensor here showed a
little more magnified here the idea is
that this is a Lego motor the Lego motor
will that will turn this relative to the
attachment that's the robot head's neck
so you the road robot will be able to do
and the robot will have eyes these are
photo sensors photo resistors actually
so the idea is going to be that there's
information available in those sensors
for figuring out where a light is so
that you could track it your job will be
to build a circuit that's this thing
that connects via cables these red
cables and yellow cables connects by a
cables over to this head will give you
the head your job will be to make the
circuit that converts the signal from
the photo resistor which is in
proportion to light and figures out how
to turn the motor to get the head to
face the light and then ship that
information down to the robot to let the
robot turn its wheels to get the body so
it's kind of like the light comes on
bright over here the robot looks at is
oh yeah that's where I want to be so
that's the idea in the third module is
to incorporate new sensing capabilities
into the robot the final module is on
probability and planning and the idea
there is to learn about how you make
systems that are robust to uncertainty
and that can make it can implement
complicated plans that they too are
robust to uncertainty so there's a
number of things that we will do
including creating maps of spaces that
the robot doesn't understand telling the
figuring out telling the robot how to
localize itself how how if it woke up
suddenly in an environment it could
figure out where it is how to make a
plan and as an example I'll show you the
kind of system that we will construct
here the idea is that we have a robot
the robot knows where it is
imagine there's a GPS in it there isn't
but imagine there is so the robot knows
where it is
and it knows where it wants to go that's
the star but it has no idea what kind of
obstacles are in the way
so you know if you were a robotic driver
in Boston you know that you started out
at home and you want to end up in MIT
but there's these annoying obstacles you
know they're called people that you
should in principle at least then you
don't miss okay so that's that's kind of
the idea so the so I know where I am I'm
the robot I know where I am I know where
I want to be and I'm going to summarize
that information here where I am is
purple where I want to be is gold and I
have a plan that's blue my plan is very
simple I don't know anything about
anything other than I mean I'm in
waltham and I want to go to Cambridge so
you know blast east so I imagine that
the best way to do there is a straight
line okay so now what I'm going to do is
turn on the robot the robot has now made
one step and I told you before about
these sonar sensors from the sonar
sensors the robot has learned now that
there seems to be something reflecting
and each of these black dots it got a
reflection from the black dots from the
from the sonar sensors that means
there's probably a wall there or a
person or something that in principle I
should avoid so and the red dots
represent okay the obstacle is so close
I really can't get there so I'm excluded
from the red spots because I'm too big
the black box the black spots seem to be
an obstacle the red spots seem to be
where I can't fit I'd still want to go
from from where I am purple to where I
want to be gold so what I do is I
compute a new plan okay then I start to
take a step along that plan and as I'm
stepping along okay so now I think that
I can't go from where I started over to
here I have to go around this wall that
I didn't know about initially so now I
just start driving and it looks fine
right I'm getting there right and so now
I know I can go straight down here oh
wait a minute there's another wall okay
well
I do now so as the robot goes around
along it didn't know when it started
what kinds of obstacles it would
encounter but as it's driving it Lauro
began work start over so the idea is
that this robot is executing a very
complicated plan the plan has in fact
many sub plans and the sub plans all
involve uncertainty it didn't know where
the walls were when it started and when
it's all done it's going to have figured
out where the walls were and provided
there's a way presumably find the way to
negotiate the maze and get to the to the
destination so the idea then is that the
if you were to ask if you were asked to
write a conventional kind of program for
solving that it might be kind of hard
because of the number of contingencies
involved what we will do is break down
the problem and figure out simple and
elegant ways to deal not only with
uncertainty but how do you make complex
plans so as I said our primary pedagogy
is going to be practice theory practice
and so that ramifies in how the course
is organized so this is a quick map of
some of the aspects of the course so
we'll have weekly lectures its lecture
on intensive in total there's only 13
lectures we'll meet once a week here for
lecture there's readings there's
voluminous readings there's readings
about every topic that we will talk talk
about and the readings were specifically
designed for this course I highly
recommend that you become familiar with
the readings if you have a question
after lecture it's probably there it's
probably explained we will do online
tutor problems we sent you an email if
you pre registered for the course so you
may already know
is the idea is going to be that there's
ways that you can prepare for the course
by doing computer exercises and we will
also use those same kinds of exercises
in all of the class sessions we will
have two kinds of lab experiences
besides lecture the other two events
that have that you have to attend are a
software lab and a design lab that's the
practice part so after you learn a
little bit about the theory by going to
lecture by by doing the reading then you
go to the lab and try some things out we
call the first lab a software lab it's a
short lab it's an hour and a half you
work individually you try things out you
write little programs through the course
where can check the program to see if
it's okay and primarily the exercises in
the software lab are due during the
software lab but on occasion that would
be extra things due a day or two later
the due dates are very clearly written
in the tutor exercises once a week
there's a design lab that's a three-hour
session in which you work with a partner
the reason for the partner is that the
intent the difference between the design
labs and the software labs is that the
design labs ask you to solve slightly
more open-ended questions the kind of
question that you might have no clue
what we're asking open-ended the kind of
thing that you will be asked to do after
you graduate design the system what do
you mean design to the system so the
idea is that working with a partner will
give you a second immediate source of
help and a little more confidence if
neither of you knows the solution so
that you raise your hand and say I don't
have a clue what's going on here so the
idea is that once a week we do a
software lab individually once a week we
do a design lab a little more open-ended
with partners there's a little bit of
written homework for total it's not much
compared to other subjects it's mostly
practice there's a nano quiz just to
help you keep pace to
make sure that you don't get too far
behind the first 15 minutes of every
design lab starts with a nano quiz the
nano quasars are intended to be simple
if you've caught up if you're up to date
so the idea is that you go to design lab
the first thing you do is a little
15-minute nano quiz the Nano quiz uses a
tutor much like the homework tutor much
like the python tutor and it's intended
to be simple but it does mean please get
to the design lab on time the nano
quizzes are administered by the software
it starts when the hour when the design
lab starts it times out 15 minutes later
so if you come ten minutes late you will
have five minutes to do something that
we plan to give you 15 minutes for we
will also have exams and interviews the
interviews are intended to be a
one-on-one conversation about how the
labs went and we will have two midterms
and a final so that's kind of the
logistics the idea behind the logistics
is practice theory practice come to the
labs try things out make sure you
understand develop a little code type it
in see if it works if it works you're on
top of things you're ready to get the
next batch of information from the
lecture and readings ok let's go on and
let's talk about the technical material
in the first module of the course in the
software module we kick the course off
talking about software engineering for
two reasons we'd like you to know about
software engineering it's an incredibly
important part of our department it's an
incredibly important part of the
engineering of absolutely any system any
modern system but we'd also like you to
know about it because it provides a very
convenient way to think about it's a
convenient language to think about the
design issues the engineering issues in
all the other parts of the class so it's
a very good place to start
so - what what I will do today is talk
about some of the very simplest ideas
about abstraction and modularity in what
I think of as the lowest level of
granularity how do you think about
abstraction and modularity at the micro
scale at the individual lines of code
scale as I said earlier we will as we
progress look at modularity and
abstraction at the higher scale but we
have to start somewhere and we're going
to start by thinking about how do you
think about abstraction of modularity at
the micro scale special note about
programming so what we are trying to do
is in the first two weeks ramp everybody
up to some level of software security
where you feel comfortable so the first
two weeks of this course is intended to
make you comfortable with programming we
don't assume you've done extensive
programming before we want you to become
comfortable that you're not behind and
that's the focus of the first two weeks
execs err sizes if you have little or no
previous background if you are
uncomfortable please do the Python tutor
exercises if you have not if you do not
have a lot of experience programming if
you're uncomfortable with with the
expectation that you can do programming
do that first that takes priority over
all the other assignments during the
first two weeks in particular if you're
uncomfortable we will run a special
Python help session on Sunday and if you
attend that you can get a free extension
the idea is completing the tutor
exercises is intended to make you feel
comfortable that you have the software
background to finish the rest of the
course
do that first we will forgive falling
behind in other things so that you feel
comfortable with programming if at the
end of two weeks you still feel
uncomfortable we have a deal with 600
the Python programming class that they
will allow you to switch your
registration from 601 to 600 but that
expires Valentine's Day so you have to
make up your mind before Valentine's Day
if you'd like to use that option so the
idea is we'd like you to be comfortable
with programming if you haven't
programmed before do the Python tutor
exercises go to software lab go to
design lab but work on the tutor
exercises the staff will help you with
them you can go to office hours there's
office hours listed in on the home page
you should try to become comfortable and
you should try to set as your goal I'm
going to be comfortable before
Valentines name and if you're not talk
to a staff staff member about that ok so
what do I want you to know about
programming well we're going to use
Python we selected Python because it's
very simple and because it lets us
illustrate some very important ideas in
software engineering in a very simple
context that's the reason one of the
reasons that it's simple is that it's an
interpreter after some initialization
the behavior of Python is to fall into
an interpreter loop the interpreter loop
is ask the user what he would like me to
do read what the user types figure out
what they're talking about and print the
result
repeat very simple what that means is
that you can learn by doing that's one
of the points of today's software lab
you can simply walk up to a computer
type the word Python what you type is in
red type the word Python it will prompt
you so this Chevron that says I'd like
you to tell me something to do I have
nothing to do if you type to Python
tries to interpret that in this
particular case Python says oh I see
that's a primitive data item that's an
integer this person wants me to
understand an integer and so it will
echo to indicating that it thinks you've
you wanted to understand a simple
integer similarly if you type five point
seven it says oh I got that that's a
float the person wants me to remember a
floating-point number and it will
similarly echo the float now of course
the floats don't have a so there's no
exact representation for floats right
there's too many of them right there's a
lot of them there's even more floats
than there are in s'right so it has an
approximation so it will print its
approximation to the float that you that
it thinks you are interested in if you
type a string hello it'll say Oh
primitive data structure string and it
will print out that string so the idea
is one of the features of Python that
makes it easy to learn is the fact that
it's interpreter based you can play
around you can learn by doing now of
course if the only thing it did was
simple data structures it would not be
very useful so the next war elem the
next more complex thing that it can do
is think about combinations if you type
two plus three it says oh I got it
this person is interested in a
combination I should combine by the plus
operator to ends
and three oh and if I do that if I
combine by the plus operator two and
three I'll get five so it prints five so
that's a way you know that it interprets
two plus three as five similarly here
except I've mixed types five point seven
plus three it says oh this user wants me
to apply the plus operator on a float
and in the end
okay well I'll upgrade the int to a
float I'll do the float version and I'll
get this which is its representation of
eight point seven so the idea is that it
will first try to interpret what you're
saying as a simple datatype if that
works it prints the result to tell you
what it thinks is going on it then will
try to interpret it as an expression and
sometimes the expressions won't make
sense in particular if you try to add an
int to a string it's going to say huh
and over the course of the first two
weeks we hope that you get familiar with
interpreting this kind of mess that's
pythons attempt to tell you what it was
trying to do on your behalf and can't
figure out what you're talking about
okay so that was simple but it already
illustrate something that's very
important and that's the idea of a
composition so the way Python works the
fact that when you added three to two
it came out five what we were doing was
composing complicated well potentially
complicated that was pretty simple
potentially complicated expressions and
reducing them to a single data structure
and so that means that in some sense
this operation three times a can be
thought of as exactly the same as if the
user had typed in 24 whenever you can
substitute for a complex expression a
simpler thing we say that the system is
compositional that's a very powerful
idea even though it's simple it's a very
powerful idea and it's an idea that you
all know you've seen it before
in algebra in arithmetic so in
arithmetic expressions you can think
about how the sum of two integers is an
int that's a closure that's a kind of a
combination that makes the system
compositional and that provides a layer
of hierarchical thinking so that in your
head even though it says 3 times 8 you
don't need to remember that anymore you
can say oh 4 for any purposes that
follow I might just as well think of 3
times 8 as being a single integer 24
it's part of many other kinds of systems
for example natural language the
simplest example in natural language is
that you can think about apples are good
as snacks apples is a noun is a plural
noun or you could substitute apples and
oranges and it makes complete sense
within that same structure so apples and
oranges are good at snacks
the combination of apples and oranges
works in every way from the point of
view of the grammar in the same way that
a simple noun apples worked what we
would like to do is use that idea as the
starting point for a more general
compositional system and a good way to
think about that is by way of names what
if we had some sequence of operations
that we think is particularly important
so that we would like to somehow
canonize that so that subsequently we
can use that sequence of operations
easily Python provides a very simple way
to do it
every programming language does is not
unique to Python but the idea is so
here's an example 2 times 2 I'm squaring
2 and get 4 3 times 3 I'm squaring 3 and
I'm getting 9 8 plus 4 times 8 plus 4
I'm squaring 8 plus 4 8 plus 4 well I
can think of that as 12 I'm squaring 12
I'm getting 144 the thing I'm trying to
illustrate there is the notion of
squaring squaring is a sequence of
operations that I would like to be able
to canonize as a single entity so that
in subsequent programs I can think of
the squaring operation as a single
operation just like I think of times the
way we say that in Python is define
square of x to be returned x squared
then having made that definition I can
say square of 6 and the answer is 36
okay this is a very small step but it
illustrates a very important point the
idea being that Python provides a
compositional facility and it's
hierarchical having defined square I can
use square just as though it were a
primitive operator and I can use square
to define higher-level
operations so for example what if I were
interested in doing lots of sums of
squares and say I'm Pythagoras right so
I might want to add the square of 2 and
the square of 4 to get 20 or the square
of 3 with the square of 4 to get 25
using that simple idea of composition we
can write a new program sum of squares
sum of squares takes two arguments X and
y and it returns the square of X and the
square of Y sum of squares doesn't care
about how you compute the square it
trusts that square knows how to do that
so the work is smaller the idea is that
Square takes care of squaring single
numbers sum of squares doesn't have to
know how to square numbers it just needs
to know how to add make a sum of squares
so what we've done is we've broken a
task which was not very complicated but
the whole idea is hierarchical we've
taken a problem and broken it into two
pieces we factored the problem into how
do you do a square and how do you sum
squares and the idea then is that this
hierarchical structure is a way of
building complex systems out of simpler
parts so that's the idea of how you
would build programs that are
compositional Python also provides a
utility for making lists for making data
structures that are compositional the
most primitive is a list so in Python
you can specify a list here's a list of
integers so the list says beginning list
end of list elements of list so those
five elements in the list the integers 1
2 3 4 5 Python doesn't care what the
elements of a list are we'll see in a
minute that that's really important but
for the time being the simplest thing
that you can imagine is a heterogeneous
list it's not critical that the list
contain just integers here's a list that
contains an int a string and int and a
string I thought doesn't care it's a
list that has four elements the first
elements in int the second elements of
string etc here's an even more complex
example here's a list of lists
how many elements are in that list three
how many elements are in that list so
the idea is that you can build more
complex data structures out of simple
ones that's the idea of compositional
factoring applied to data just like it
was important when we were thinking
about procedures to associate names with
procedures that's what death did we can
also think about associating names with
data structures and that's what we use
something that Python calls a variable
for so I can say B is 3 and that
associates the data item 3 with the
label B I can say X is 5 times to point
to my time we'll figure out what I mean
by the expression on the right it'll
figure out that I'm composing by using
the star operator which is multiplying
an integer and a float which will give
me a float the answer to that's going to
be a floating-point number and it will
assign a label X to that floating point
number you can have a more complicated
list a data structure and associate the
name Y with it then having associated
the name Y you get many of the same
benefits of associating a name of the
data structure that we got previously in
associating a name with an operation so
we can say Y of 0 and what that means is
what's the 0th element of the data
structure Y so the 0th element of the
data structure Y is a list 1 2 3 Python
has some funky notations the minus 1
element is the last one so the minus 1
element of Y is 7 8
nine and it's completely hierarchical if
I ask for the minus one element of Y I
get seven eight nine but then if I ask
for the first element of that result I
get eight okay everything is everything
is clear
okay just make sure everything is clear
I want to ask you a question but to kick
off the idea of working together I'd
like you to think about this question
with your neighbor
so before thinking about this question
everybody stand up introduce yourself to
your neighbor
so now so now I'd like to I'd like you
to each discuss with your neighbor
the list that is best represented by
which of the following figures 1 2 3 4
or 5 none of the above and in 30 seconds
I'm going to ask everybody to raise a
hand with a number of fingers indicating
the right answer you're allowed to talk
that's the whole point of having a
partner
yeah
okay I'd like everybody now to raise
their hand put up the number of fingers
that show the answer and I want to tally
fantastic everybody gets it okay so
what's so which one you like three why
do you like three somebody explain it to
me it just looks better it's pattern
recognition
what's good about three compositional
what is the compositional element in the
pictures what represents what okay a
represents a that's pretty easy right so
that takes care of the bulk of the
figures what's the blue lines represent
I didn't understand then they represent
left where where is the list on Peters
the vertex the vertices are this so in
three at the highest level we have a
list that's composed of how many
elements to the first element of that
list is and the second element of a list
is another list that's the hierarchical
party right that second list has how
many elements financer refers you got
what is the list represented by number
two a single square bracket a comma B
comma C comma D comma E square bracket
right what is the list represented by
that one
Wow it's not a list right what is it who
knows so we couldn't make that a
variable if we said is variable that
comprises B and C then we have the
problem of how we're going to associate
variables and elements into this list
right so the weird thing about this one
and let's see that one's weird this
one's also kind of weird this one's
weird because we're giving names to
lists in a fashion that's not showed up
here right that's not to say you
couldn't invent a meeting it's just that
it doesn't matter well to that
representation similarly over here we
seem to be giving the the name B to the
element a and then the name C to the
element B what on earth it's not clear
what we're doing there either okay so
the point is to get you thinking about
the abstract representation of lists and
how that maps into a complex data
structure that was the whole point okay
so we've talked about then four things
so far how do you think about operations
in a hierarchical fashion and the idea
was composition we think about composing
simple operations to make bigger
compound operations that's a way of
saying there's this set of operations
that I want to call foo so every time I
do this complicated thing that has three
pages of code that's one foo and that's
a way that we can then combine Foos in
some other horribly complicated way to
make big foods right so the idea is
composition that's the first idea the
second is the is associating a name with
that composition that's what def does
define name name of a subroutine
so we thought about composing operations
associating names with them we compose
data in terms of lists and we associated
names with those lists in terms of
variables the next thing we want to
think about is a higher-order construct
where we would like to conglomerate into
one data structure both data and
procedures Python has a concept called a
class that lets us do that in Python you
make a new class by saying to the Python
prompt I want a new class called student
and then understood there is this thing
which we will call an attribute an
attribute of to a class is simply a data
item associated with the class and a
method a method is just a procedure that
is associated with a class so there's
this the single item class called
student that has one piece of data its
attribute school and one procedure which
is the method calculate final rate so
then this is the kind of data structure
you might imagine that a registrar would
have it's a way to associate so the idea
here is that everybody here is a student
they all have a school and they all have
a way of calculating their final grade
that's a very narrow view that may be a
registrar we have so classes having
defined them we can then use the class
to define an instance so an instance is
a data structure that inherits all of
the structure from the class but also
provides a mechanism for having specific
data associated with the instance so in
Python I say meri is a student by
mentioning the name of the class and
putting parentheses on it I say give me
an instance of the Stute
so now Mary is a name associated with an
instance of the class student John is
similarly an instance of the class
student
so both Mary and John have schools in
fact they're both the same the school of
Mary and the school of John are both MIT
but I can you I can extend the instance
of Mary to include a new attribute the
section number so that Mary's section
number is three and John's section
number is four so this provides a way
it's a higher-order concept right we
thought of a way to aggregate operations
in the complicated operations data into
complicated data classes aggregate data
and operations classes allow us to
create a structure and then generate
instances and then the instances have
access to those features that were
defined in the class but also have the
ability to define their own unique
attributes and methods you can also use
a class to define a subclass so here I'm
defining the sub class student 601 all
student 600 ones are members of the
class student the reverse is not true so
all students in all students 601
entities inherit everything that a
student has but all 601 students share
some other things besides having a
school which all students have 601
students also have a lecture day elektra
time and a method for calculating tutor
scores not all students have a 'we have
a method for calculating tutor scores
but six members of the class student 601
do so this again represents a way of
organizing data and operations in a way
that makes it easier to compose higher
bigger more complex structures
the final thing that I want to talk to
about today is the specific gory details
for how python manages the association
between names and entities we've already
seen two of those naming operations is
via death and it gives rise to the name
of a procedure variables are ways of
naming data structures now we've seen a
way of naming classes and in fact it's
helpful if you understand so Python
associates names and entities in a very
simple straightforward fashion and if
you know the ground rules it makes it
very easy to deal with and if you don't
know the ground rules it makes it very
hard to deal with so what's the ground
rules here's the gory details so Python
associates names with value values in
what python calls a binding environment
an environment is just a list that
associates a name and an entity so if
you were to type B equals 3 what Python
is actually doing is it's building this
environment when you type D equals 3 it
adds to the environment and a name B and
associates that name with the integer 3
when you type x equals 2.2 it adds a
name X and associates it with the float
to point to when you say foo is minus
506 times 2 it makes the name foo and
associates it with an int - 10 12 then
if you ask Python about be the rule is
look it up in the environment and type
the thing that'd be reversed - so when
you type B what Python really does is it
goes to the environment it says do I
have some entity called B
well yes I do it happens to be an in
three so it prints three if you ask what
is a Python says okay in my environment
do I have some name a it doesn't find it
so it prints out this cryptic message
that basically says sorry guys I can't
find something called a in the current
environment that's the key to the way
Python does all name bindings so in
general there's a global environment you
start typing the Python it just starts
adding and modifying the bindings in the
binding environment so if you type a was
3 and n type a it'll find 3 if you then
type B who's a plus 2 it evaluates the
right-hand side relative to the current
environment so it first looks here and
it says do I have something called a not
yes I it's an integer 3 substitute that
do I know what 2 is oh yeah that's just
an end do I know what plus is oh yeah
that's the thing that combines two ends
so it decides that a plus 2 it evaluates
a plus 2 in the current environment it
gets 5 and it says oh I'm trying to do a
new equals a new Association a new
variable make the name be point to this
evaluated in the current environment so
B gets associated with the int 5 then if
I do this line it evaluates B plus 1 in
the current environment B is 5 in the
current environment it adds one it gets
6 and then it says associate this thing
sex with B so it overwrites the B which
had been bound to 5 and it's B is now
bound to 6
okay
so the whole thing the way it treats
variables the way it associates in the
way python associates a name with a
value in a variable is evaluate the
right hand side according to the current
environment then change the current
environment to reflect the new binding
what it does in the case of subroutines
is very similar when you say so here's
an illustration of the local environment
that is generated by this piece of code
when I say a equals 2 it generates a
name in the local environment a it
evaluates the right-hand side and finds
2 so it makes a binding in the local
environment where the name a is
associated with the integer 2 then i say
define square of x to be returned x
squared that's more complicated python
says oh i'm defining a new operation
it's a procedure the procedure has a
formal argument X it has a body return x
times X I'm going to have to remember
all of that stuff so I'm trying to
define a new procedure called square
it's going to make a binding for square
so in the future if somebody says the
word square it'll find out Oh square I
remember that way square it's a
procedure
just like the binding for a variable
might be an int the binding for a
procedure is the name of the procedure
then in the procedure which is some
other data structure outside the
environment it's got to remember the
formal parameters in this case X and the
body and for the purpose of resolving
what do the variables mean it needs to
remember what was the by
environment in which this subroutine was
defined so that's the that's this arrow
so this this sequence says make a new
binding square points to a procedure the
procedure has the formal argument X it
has the body return X times X and it has
the binding it has a came from the
environment
II won the current environment ok is
everybody clear up so the idea is that
the environment associates names with
things the thing could be a data item or
it could be a procedure then when you
call a procedure it makes a new
environment so what happens then when I
try to evaluate a form square of a plus
2 what Python does is it says ok I need
to figure out what square is so it looks
it up in the environment and it finds
out that Square is a procedure fine I
know how to deal with procedures so then
it figures out this procedure has a
formal argument X ok if I'm going to run
this procedure I'm going to have to know
what X means so Python makes a new
environment here is labeled e to
separate from the the global environment
II won it makes a new environment that
will associate X with something doesn't
know what it is yet it just knows that
the square is a procedure that takes a
formal argument X so Python makes a new
environment e 2 with X pointing to
something then Python evaluates the
argument a plus 2 in the environment II
won you called square of a plus 2 in the
environment a 1 so it figures out what
did you mean by a plus a plus 3 while
you were in the environment II won so it
means whatever a plus 3 would have meant
if he had just typed a plus 3 in that
environment
so you evaluate a plus three in the
environment e1 and you get five so then
this new environment e to that is set up
for this procedure square associates
five with X now it's ready to run the
body so now it runs this procedure
return x times X but now when it's
trying to resolve its variables it looks
it up in e2 so he says I want to do the
procedure the body x times X I need to
know what X is and I need to know it
twice look up what X means but I will
look it up in my e2 environment that was
built specifically for this procedure
and fortunately there's an X there so it
finds out that X is 5 it multiplies 5
times 5 it gets the answer is 25 it
returns 25 and then it destroys this
environment e 2 because it was only
necessary for the time when it was
running the procedure body cycler ok so
a slightly more difficult example
illustrates what happens whenever
everything is not defined in the current
local environment what if I type define
biz of a well I create a new name in the
in the local environment that points to
a procedure the procedure has a formal
parameter a and a body that returns a
plus B the procedure also has was
defined within the environment ie one
which I'll keep track of then if I say B
equals sex that makes a new binding in
the global environment B who sex then if
I try to run this of to lookup biz oh
that's a procedure formal parameter a
make an environment has an A in it what
should I put in a evaluate the argument
to okay a is to put two here now I'm
ready to run the body run the body in
the environment e two when I run return
a plus B in e2 I have to first figure
out a well that's easy a is two then I
have to figure out B what's B so how do
you get six so this local environment
that was created for the formal
parameter has as its parent II one
because that's where the procedure was
defined so it doesn't find B in the in
this local environment so it goes to the
parent do you have a beam and it could
in principle propagate up a chain of
environments so you could construct this
hierarchically so it will resolve
bindings in the most recent environment
that has that binding so the answer then
is that when you run bizzle to this b
gets associated with that B okay so
that's how how the environments work for
simple procedures and simple data
structures it's very similar for the way
it works with classes so imagine that I
had this data and I wanted to represent
that in Python what I might do is look
at the common features the courses are
all the same the rooms are all the same
the buildings are all the same the ages
are highly variable so I might want to
create a class that has the common data
so I might do this class staff601
the course is 6:01 the building's 34 the
room is this the way python implements a
class is as an environment
executing this set of statements builds
the
class environment this is it it's a list
of bindings here I'm binding the name
course to the string 601 etc if there
were a method I would do the same thing
except it would look like a procedure
that so this creates the staff601
environment staff601 because I executed
the class and statement this class
statement that creates a binding in the
local environment staff601 which points
to the new environment so now in the
future when python encounters the name
staff601 it will discover that that's in
him that's a that's an environment
Python implements classes as
environments so now when I want to
access elements within a class I use a
special notation it's a dot notation
Python regards dots as ways of
navigating an environment when python
parses staff point room
it looks up staff601 in the current
environment if it finds an environment
it then says oh I know about this dot
room thing all I do is I look up the
room name in the environment staff601
and when it does that it gets the answer
501 and the same sort of thing happens
here it looks up staff601 it finds an
environment it looks up Kunis it finds
out there is no such thing well no
that's not true
so it creates coolness within 601 and
the signs of variable signs an integer
love it too right so then the way
classes the way python treats methods is
completely analogous so no excuse me
instances
doing instances first if I make Pat be
an instance of staff601 Pat is an
instance of the class staff601 Pat is
implemented as an environment so when I
make Pat Pat points to a new environment
here III the parent of III is the class
that Pat belongs to which is here II -
and when I make the instance it's empty
but now if I ask what is Pat course will
Pat points to this environment does this
environment have something called a
course no does the parent yes course is
bound to the string 601 so Pat course is
601 just the same as staff601 dot course
had in 601 Pat's a new instant Pat is an
instance it's a new environment with the
class environment as its parent you can
add instances you can add attributes to
instances and all that does is populate
the environment associated with the
instance you can add methods to classes
and that does the same thing so here
I've got the class staff601 which has a
method salutation and instance variables
course building in room so when I build
that structure staff601 points to an
environment that contains salutation
which is a procedure in addition to a
bunch of instance variables so now all
the rules that we've talked about with
regard to environments apply now to this
class so in particular I can say
staff601 siutation of Pat when python
parsons staff601
it finds an environment it says dot
siutation oh I know how to do that
within the within the environment
staff601 look for a binding for the name
salutation do I find one well yeah there
it is it points to a procedure so staff
dot salutation is a procedure do just
the same things that we would have done
with a simple procedure the only
difference here is that the procedure
came from a class in this particular
case the the subroutine that I define
has a formal parameter self so then that
build that's going to have to build when
I try to evaluate it that has to build a
local that has to build a binding for
self which is set to pat-pat was an
environment so self gets pointed to path
so now when I run staff dot 601
salutation on Pat it behaves as though
that generic method was applied to the
instance path we'll do that a lot it's a
little bit of redundancy we know that
path is a member of staff 601 so we will
define a special form or I should say
Python defines a special form that makes
that easy to say this is the way we will
usually say the instance Pat should run
the class method salutation on itself
this is simply a simplified notation
that means precisely that
okay so what we covered today then was
supposed to be the most elementary ideas
in how you construct modular programs
modularity at the small scale how do you
make operations that are hierarchical
data structures and classes what we will
do for the rest of the week is practice
those activities